every month thousands of people arrive
in the EU seeking asylum in 2016 alone
1.3 million people applied for asylum in
the EU which is actually a decrease on
the year before but it is still a large
burden for countries like Italy and
Greece where migrants arrive first the
European Asylum support office is based
in Malta established in 2010 it
coordinates asylum procedures throughout
Europe the main idea of the European
Asylum Agency is that we have to work
together that the European solution that
is what we need not a member state
solutions but we need one common
European solution this means training
country officials about asylum laws
facilitating the flow of information and
data across borders or working with
Europe's courts and tribunals to
regulate asylum law across the block the
office is there to help in refugee
hotspots those places that receive a
steady flow of migrants for instance the
agency deploy support workers on the
ground to help people who have just
arrived and identifies vulnerable people
like unaccompanied minors and provides
them with the support they need in 2016
there were more than 65,000
unaccompanied minors who applied for
asylum in the EU armed with data like
this the agency is able to coordinate
and help the people who need it most